is about 40 kilometers west of the
Libyan Capital Tripoli
it's known for its plentiful farmlands
and great tasting oranges and grapefruit
they are big bright and juicy but the
orange Harvest will soon come to an end
farmer fight
owns this small land with 250 orange
trees he says it's been difficult to
maintain the last couple of years
there is a clear lack of support from
the government we are suffering because
there is a severe lack of fertilizer and
pesticides in the market and the
government no longer subsidizes them the
government should encourage and help us
by providing our needs so we can
increase domestic production and not
rely on Imports
in the past oranges from Western Libya
have accounted for an estimated 70
percent of the nation's needs they were
even exported to neighboring countries
but not anymore
is a fruit wholesaler he says Libyan
oranges are much better than those from
abroad
the last couple of years the government
has not been able to provide Farmers
with fertilizer so they have to buy it
in the private sector it's expensive the
price of production increases so the
farmer struggles the merchant struggles
and the customers can't afford it
is from the Ministry of Agriculture and
says at least a hundred and fifty
thousand Farmers have registered to get
fertilizer
Farmers have every right to be angry due
to instability we have not been able to
provide them with their needs prices for
domestic Goods have increased as a
result the lack of affordable fertilizer
in pesticide has allowed foreign fruits
especially from Egypt to gain a much
bigger market share it's also made
living oranges significantly more
expensive
Farmers like Faisal hope the government
acts quickly so their crops can freely
compete in the market and earn them a
living Malik trainer Al Jazeera Western
Libya
oh